ya estamos en la parte final del
problema solo tenemos que evaluar el
rotacional df y hacer el producto punto
con el vector que obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior ya que tenemos esto simplemente
nos falta evaluar la integral doble así
que para allá de una vez ir concretando
esto vamos a calcular el rotacional de f
entonces el rotacional de f
de hecho nuestro campo vectorial efe lo
acabo de copiar aquí para que tengamos
muy presente de qué es lo que estamos
hablando lo podemos entender como un un
determinante el determinante que no es
tal cual un determinante simplemente es
como digamos una regla nemotécnica para
acordarnos muy bien ponemos en el primer
renglón a los vectores canónicos a los
vectores y jk en el siguiente renglón
ponemos la parcial respecto de x parcial
respecto de ye y la parcial respecto de
z y en el último renglón vamos a poner
las entradas del campo vectorial
entonces la primera entrada es menos de
cuadrada las siguientes equis y la
última es
cuadrada vamos a calcular esto ok
entonces nos tomamos primero el vector y
el vector y simplemente es calcular el
determinante de esta pues digamos de
esta forma matricial que no es tal cual
una matriz entonces nos tomamos el sub
determinante de esto y es la parcial de
zeta cuadrada respecto de iu que es cero
menos la parcial respecto de zeta de x
que también es cero porque x no depende
de z así que esta primera parte no no es
relevante para para este rotacional cuál
es la siguiente parte nos tomamos el
vector jota o que iba a ser jota que
multiplica hay que ponerle su signo
menos recuerden que vamos alternando el
signo entonces cuando tomamos el vector
jota quitamos el renglón y la columna y
nos queda la parcial respecto de x dz
cuadrada que es cero
- la parcial respecto de z de menos de
cuadrada que también es cero todos esos
no dependen de las variables por las
cuales estamos derivando entonces toda
esta parte no va vamos a tomar ahora la
que tomamos acá que multiplica a la
parcial respecto de xx que es 1 y la
parcial bueno nos falta menos la parcial
respecto de ye de menos de cuadrada pero
eso es menos 2 y como estamos restando
nos queda más 2 entonces toda esta parte
no fue relevante simplemente nos
quedamos con que el rotacional es uno
más 2 y por el vector k
el unitario en la dirección zeta que
vamos a hacer ahora pues vamos a
sustituir eso en nuestra integral
entonces tenemos la integral de 0 a 1
que es la para la variable r de la
integral de 0 a 2 pi para la variable
teta del rotacional
aunque y el rotacional que es uno más
dos por el vector k que multiplica al
vector que obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior que es rj más cerca y todo esto
lo integramos respecto de theta respecto
de r vamos a simplificar esto porque
cuando uno tiene cada punto bueno este
este producto interior lo podemos
distribuir entonces nos queda uno más
dos por r que multiplica a cada punto
jota pero acá punto j como son
ortogonales es decir tenemos que el
vector k es el 0 0 1 y el vector j es el
vector 0 10 entonces al hacer el
producto interior entre estos dos que
simplemente multiplicar entrada por
entrada y sumarlo entonces nos queda 0
si nos queda 0 entonces lo único que nos
queda es hacer cada punto acá que es 1 y
simplemente nos queda entonces dejen me
dejen ir escribiendo esto un poco más
abajo
entonces nos queda r que multiplica a 12
y entonces vamos a ir escribiendo esto
esto es la integral de 0 a 1 de la
integral de 0 a 2 y ok la integra la
ciudad 2 pide quien dijimos r que
multiplica a 1 r más dos veces r porque
pero y vamos a recordar quién era y es
rs no detecta entonces si multiplicamos
por r nos queda dos ere cuadrada seno de
teta y todo esto vamos a integrarlo
respecto a teta ok
respecto a r vamos a ver ahora si
quienes esto porque al integrar respecto
de teta simplemente si nos damos cuenta
la integral de r respecto de teta pues
es es receta ok y ahora si integramos 12
cuadradas enoé teta respecto de teta es
2 r cuadrada por la por la integral de
ese 9 teta que es menos coseno etc
entonces déjenme déjenme quitar esto y
le pongo menos 2 r cuadrada coseno de
teta que todo esto hay que evaluarlo
entre 0 y 2 para que de esta forma y que
es lo que hay que hacer ahora pues
integral respecto de r de 0 a 1
respecto de r y esto por supuesto es muy
sencillo ya es una integral definida de
una sola variable vamos a ver quien es
esto esto es igual a la integral de 0 a
1 ok de quién es esto vamos a ver vamos
a ir calculando porque rt está evaluado
en dos pies
r por 2 y menos 2 r cuadrada y coseno de
tt valuado en 2 pi pues es 1 ok ya todo
esto hay que restarle cuando evaluamos
en cero pero el reporte está evaluado en
cero es cero y simplemente restamos dos
r cuadrada coseno de cero que es 1
entonces aquí podemos hacer los más
tenemos 12 re cuadrada y menos 12 re
cuadrada estos dos se cancelan y
simplemente la integral que me toca
resolver es 2 pi por r respecto de r
y esto simplemente es esto es muy
sencillo verdad porque esto es 2 pi por
la integral de r por la integral de r es
r cuadrada entre 2 x 2 pi
simplemente me queda para borrar por r
cuadrada y esto evaluado entre 0 y 1
pero en uno vale y por 1 al cuadrado
espí y al restarle cuando evaluamos en
cero r cuadrada en cero es cero y nos
queda menos cero que esto simplemente es
pi y aquí podemos ya sacar los redobles
porque ya terminamos el problema después
de cuatro vídeos así que sólo para
recordar lo que hemos hecho en estos
últimos vídeos nos pedían calcular
queríamos calcular esta integral verdad
la integral a lo largo de una curva de
nuestro campo vectorial
pero bueno utilizábamos el teorema de
stocks para hacerlo
digamos lateralmente después en otros
vídeos vamos a hacerlo está vamos a
calcular esta integral de línea
directamente para que vean que si en
efecto es el mismo resultado después
calculamos la integral de superficie
sobre esta región que era suave por
trozos con fronteras también suave por
trozos y la trayectoria de la de la cual
queríamos integrar pues era la frontera
de esta región ok
entonces al evaluar esta integral de
superficie que fue lo que hicimos en
todos estos vídeos ya después de varias
cuentas llegamos a que el resultado es
pi